and after i finished the five days of
pax levitt
i reverted to negative on an antigen
test for three days in a row
uh and then on the fourth day just to be
absolutely certain i tested myself again
and i reverted back to positive by the
antigen test
so it was sort of what people are
referring to as a pax livid rebound
and then over the next day or so i
started to feel really poorly much worse
than in the first go-around
[Music]
how you doing people i'm dave rubin this
is the ruin report it is june 30th 2022
happy birthday to my mom happy 40th mom
i cannot believe you are younger than me
how did that happen i hope you have a
great day and there's something coming
to the house keep an eye out for a
package something's
a coming happy birthday mom love you uh
all right we are live of course on
rumble on youtube and on blaze tv
subscribe if you haven't and uh today is
mostly
uh a reuben report locals community q a
but we're going to talk about a couple
things first first one's sort of a
breaking story that's happening right
now related uh to jordan peterson we're
also going to talk a little bit uh about
bill maher who seems to be slowly taking
that red pill but you know it takes time
for these people to actually swallow it
uh but let's start with jordan peterson
a couple things related to jordan first
last night you may have seen this uh the
daily wire
ben shapiro's uh news and entertainment
and cultural uh
website
thing big thing it's a big thing at this
point uh they announced that they've
signed jordan peterson so uh that's
great news obviously for jordan and our
friends over at the daily wire
but the day was not perfect for jordan
because earlier in the day uh he was
suspended from twitter he remains
suspended on twitter right now and let's
throw the image up right here so here's
the tweet that got him suspended now i
just want to clarify for uh chronology
of this thing the tweet he put up there
is on june 22nd he was not suspended
until yesterday june 29th but the tweet
is remember when pride was a sin
and ellen page just had her breasts
removed by a criminal
physician
so ellen page is the actress who
transitioned and i suppose is now known
as elliott page and she had her breasts
removed i don't know about the bottom
situation or anything like that but
throw the image up one more time what
twitter said about jordan's tweet and
again it was left up for a week
they said that it violated their rules
against hateful conduct you may not
promote violence against threaten or
harass other people on the basis of race
ethnicity national origin sexual
orientation gender gender identity
religious attention
sorry religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease now jordan
obviously did not promote violence
against anyone he is a clinical
psychologist and a world-renowned author
and speaker those were his thoughts uh
jordan has told me personally he is not
going to delete the tweet twitter will
not put him back unless he deletes the
tweet and he has said to me he will see
who blinks first uh of course myself
and several other uh people on twitter
are trying to defend jordan and that
then gets the progressive woke
genderless brigade to report you
repeatedly so my twitter account has
been under attack and i keep getting
these messages from twitter that i am
being reported to the german authorities
but fortunately at the moment i have
evaded
the german authorities there you go
twitter is required by german law to
provide notice users who are reported by
people in germany so germany's coming
after me we'll see what happens anyway
this is just a perfect example it's not
that the twitter thing is so important
and that we should all be lost in the
minutia of social media but these are
the cultural flames that end up becoming
these big uh fiery outbursts in our
political situation and it's like of
course twitter allows hate
of course twitter allows people to say
mean things and attack people and do all
of that stuff and in no way was jordan
instigating violence against anyone or
or against elliot or ellen or anyone
else ellen whatever whatever
or anyone else so anyway i just wanted
to put that out there um before we get
to this bill maher situation oh and we
have a hilarious video from this lady
kamala harris you know her the uh the
vice president over there she's not very
good at her job but
she's second in line like basically the
second most powerful person on earth uh
she's a liar and we'll get to that in a
second but real quick let me talk to you
guys about real estate agents i trust
you know buying or selling a home is
already one of the most stressful things
you can do and it can be 10 times worse
if you're not working with the right
agent generally speaking our homes are
our biggest investment that's a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the introduction
and then follows you through the buying
or selling process to make sure that
you're satisfied the agents they work
with have long track records and are the
best sellers in their field they're part
of this audience they share your values
and they're almost anywhere you want to
go the process is simple just go to
realestateagentsidetrust.com
and provide them with some basic info
they'll reach out to you to make an
introduction to a preferred agent in
your town and then you move and then
you're happy there you go
all right so let's talk a little bit
about bill maher i won't bludgeon you
over the head you know my thoughts he is
on his way to being red-pilled but the
question with all of the libs all of the
mainstream non-woke libs is can they get
to the end of the road can they suck it
up and say gosh darn it those
conservatives aren't a bunch of white
supremacists
mean racist people and by golly they've
been the ones really fighting critical
race theory and wokeness and gender
lunacy and endless inflation and gas
prices and it's the democrats who are
destroying all of the things that i
purport to believe in and my liberal
world
can they get there well bill maher seems
like he might be on the way i'm not
holding my breath on this uh we covered
joe rogan yesterday who seems like he's
on the way and said that he might
support ron desantis uh for
uh president uh although ron de santa
has not even said he's running for
president but either way good sign uh
but here's maher
uh basically saying something kind of
nice about the santas and desantis i
mean he's just more he's more vibrant if
you like people who don't lose elections
and you know
well he's also not plagued by a scandal
the way that trump is he's a stronger
candidate the january six hearings have
been very compelling to watch but a
little part of me thinks this might
actually be bad for the democrats
because if trump is too weak to win the
republican nomination it's going to be
to stannis and desantis could be biden
well easily ever anybody could beat
biden
who could not beat this
[Applause]
trump might be the one guy who could
lose to biden
but desantis you're right because
because he's a winner he's runs the
third largest state trump is a hotel
greeter
[Laughter]
who lost his insurrection failed
okay so there's a couple interesting
things there so first off obviously bill
maher would never vote for trump right
he has complete trump derangement
syndrome and that's never gonna happen
but what he's softly signaling there and
even though he does it in a glib way and
he's dismissive of desantis like it's
just that he can win elections it's sort
of like biden is horrible we all know it
and desantis kind of ain't that bad and
again although bill maher will never
fully admit it you may remember a video
we showed you a couple months ago where
he was talking about all these great
things happening out of florida
and he as i told you yesterday he shot
his most recent hbo special right here
in florida a couple weeks ago he was
like but i'll never move to florida
but what's happening is as the rubber
meets the road as these guys get to the
end of their ideas they're going holy
cow i'm going to be put in a position
where i may have to vote for the scary
conservative in the case now
interestingly the two people he's
sitting with there uh both also have
trump derangement syndrome andrew
sullivan who's supposedly a good liberal
who keeps saying that voting for biden
over trump uh was still a good idea
which obviously makes no sense and the
other woman i can't even remember her
name
but she has tried to cancel me many many
times and wrote some awful articles
about me and it's like these people it's
like come on you're all welcomed to this
other side this other truly diverse side
but you gotta get there you gotta get
there and you gotta realize that you
can't be destroying the very people who
have been doing it and getting us on
that good path before you
but
what they also were talking about there
is that nobody likes biden and i'm
telling you right now it is just so
obvious something has so shifted in the
ether in just the last two weeks where
now everyone's talking about his
incompetence everyone's talking about
will he run won't he run everyone's
talking about that this thing ain't
working and that he doesn't know what
he's doing and they just can't hide it
much more now a whole bunch of us have
been saying that for about two years
even before he was elected uh but here
is kamala harris and boy she just loves
she's all joe all the time
joe biden is running for re-election and
i will be his ticket mate
full stop pull stop
sit
joe biden is running and i will be his
ticket mate full stop full stop i mean
watch body language man watch body
language joe biden is running for
re-election and i will be his ticket
mate
full stop pull stop
that's it
i think joe biden is totally competent i
don't think he has any problems i think
he's fully able to complete a sentence i
don't think there's anything cognitively
wrong with him i think things are going
really well in the country i think the
economy is going great i think gas is
cheap i think we know what we're doing
when it comes to ukraine and all the
myriad of other problems i mean it's
such a lie it's such a lie she will be
the first one to throw joe biden under
the bus once they're done with him and
they are almost done with him i don't
know if you're watching any of these
videos coming out of europe right now
where they have this big i think it's
the g7 summit over there and these
videos keep leaking where joe is just
standing there he doesn't know where he
is it's obvious it's obvious but trust
me the second it is politically
expedient for that woman who as i always
tell you was poland zero in her own
party to get rid of joe so she thinks
she can ascend to the throne she will be
the first one the first one to throw him
under the bus so you're a liar kamala
harris i know you guys are all so deep
in the lies it's like all you can do is
lie right like once you've lied it's one
thing to like lie a little it's one
thing some white lies but once your
whole thing is just based on lies what
you say about other people what your
beliefs are etc etc once you have just
lied as the complete architecture of
everything around you then you got to
keep lying and that is what kamala
harris and the rest of the democrats are
doing at the moment
let's get to some reuben report
community q a
kathy says what is on your fourth of
july grill are you sending up some
fireworks so
as you know it was my birthday a couple
days ago and uh michael who's a little
under the weather today so he's not in
studio with us but michael i assume
you're watching the show um michael gave
me fireworks for my birthday so we will
be setting off some fireworks you guys
going to come over and we're going to
blow up some [ __ ] and see what happens
it can be very exciting
we got all kinds of hot dogs and burgers
and uh i think my sister and her kids
and husband are gonna come over and
maybe some other friends and we'll do
some barbecuing and all sorts of good
stuff we're just gonna relax honestly
just relax it's nice to have a three-day
weekend i'm so happy to be in the free
state of florida uh where people will be
happy and joyous and there's american
flags all over the place you have to
remember i came from this place called
los angeles this communist hello you put
a you put an american flag outside your
house they could they could come get you
so i'm very appreciative
of being in florida for this fourth of
july and i guess
maybe we'll go down to miami beach they
must do some big fireworks over there
see what's going on i'm very excited
very excited love america did you know
that freedom fan says if you could
hijack biden's teleprompter what message
would you insert oh very simple help me
help me
i need help
help me they're abusing me elder abuse
call someone life alert i've fallen and
i can't get up the man needs help
really like joking aside for a second he
he really needs help
the country needs help for sure but when
it breaks what they have done to him
whether it is drugging him
the note cards they put in front of him
did you see the image of the note card
that they had from him at the g7 the
other day where it was literally they
literally wrote on a note card you in
capital letters you sit in capital
letters your seat i mean that's the
level that we're at right now you sit in
your seat they are abusing this dude and
they're abusing him so just so that they
could keep the show going long enough
until they could usher in whatever is
coming after him whether it's the aoc
thing
or the kamala thing or it's michelle
obama whatever is the far worse thing
and that is why a guy like me who's not
a traditional conservative voter
realized that donald trump was the
firewall to stop this thing and man a
lot of people i suppose didn't see it
and they regret it now but how many of
them will have the maya culpa and that's
always why i'm pushing on bill maher all
the time that's why i'm pushing on rogan
and some of these other people it's like
yeah there were a bunch of people that
got it right and bill maher you may not
like those religious people but man they
they
set the ground for the world that you
want to live in so get on board dude
derek says how do you feel about jordan
joining the daily wire personally i'm
very excited for him and can't see i
can't wait to see the content he makes
with him well first off uh the very
first episode of jordan's new show on
the daily wire has a spectacular
i'm talking like grade a
top of the line guest
uh happens to be the guy talking right
now what are the chances yeah i went uh
to uh their florida studios that the
daily wire has they're based mostly in
nashville but they've got some great
studios right here in florida and i tape
the first episode of the new jordan
peterson show on the daily wire we went
for an hour and a half no stops and it
probably as i tweeted out this morning a
little clip of it
it probably was the most well without
question it was the most personal
conversation i've ever had on camera
jordan interviewing me but probably the
most important conversation i've ever
had on camera and it's all about having
kids
and
what my what is changing in my life
right now and why i did it and the
challenges of uh parenting when you're
in a same-sex relationship and how this
affects things culturally and
politically and we really got into the
muck admirer of this thing because
there's a lot of questions you know it's
one thing to just say oh it's great just
have kids and gay people be married and
all of these things but there are a lot
of important things to talk about and we
went as deep as we possibly could and
right when it ended we thought man we
just scratched the surface
so we're going to put up a clip or two
on our channel as well right we are
doing that i think we're doing that
we're we're trying to find out we're
trying to find out but if not you can
watch at least a portion of it for now
on jordan's page when you're done with
this naturally but i'm very excited i
think it's a great move for the daily
wire and you know they're also bringing
on dennis prager and prageru to do some
things and anywhere that i see
alternative media being built whether
it's the blaze whether it's daily wire
it doesn't matter it's like build build
build and let the other things burn you
don't just burn the left is into just
burning everything down well it's okay
those things can go away right disney
plus can go away mainstream media can go
away cnn can die netflix can collapse
well okay we don't want to just sit in
the collapse of everything forever we
want to build that's why i started
locals it's why we're doing what we do
here and that's all i've got to say
about that
dave
says smoking a 14 pound boston butt this
weekend i'm thinking this could take 20
hours you ever done one i've never done
a boston butt however
man they're gonna clip that take that
one that one
however um actually for my birthday
david did get me a 17 pound
wagyu brisket which is in our freezer
right now and i am super psyched i mean
that thing you could probably smoke it
yeah you said 20 hours for 14 pounds
yeah you could easily do 20 hours on
this thing so i'll probably maybe we'll
do it this weekend even probably set it
at like
8 o'clock the night before and then
hopefully it's ready for for dinner the
next night um i as you know i love that
smoker love that big green egg and uh no
the boston butt i'm gonna have to look
into the boston butt oh they're gonna
clip that one too
patrick says dave your conversation with
jordan on parenting was profoundly
moving oh so people have seen it already
okay great uh both for its intellectual
rigor and its unrelenting honesty you've
spoken of the increasing role of faith
in your life do you think that meeting
jordan was part of the divine plan for
your life i believe that it was
yeah i do believe that it was because
there's simply no other way to explain
it
right like and that that was something i
mentioned this in the interview with
jordan
and thanks for watching it um you know
when i was on tour with jordan
he's out there and as i said in the
interview it's like i had the best seat
in the house every night because i was
always stage right
you know so i would do the intro
shake jordan's hand give him a hug he'd
go out there for an hour and a half but
i'd be sitting on the stage watching the
show every night and the guy's giving a
different lecture every single night
sometimes about the book sometimes about
12 rules sometimes about one rule
sometimes about social media like
something sometimes about a hit piece
that was written that day sometimes
about his personal life like it was
different every night and i got to see
that and and by being part of that i saw
all these people bettering their lives
and i really remember thinking it was
like man whatever was left in my life to
fix and everyone's got stuff and i'm not
gonna sit here and tell you that i've
completely perfected all of it of course
i have not everything is always a work
in progress we're always fighting our
demons we're always hopefully trying to
get better in all those things but i
really remember thinking over and over
like if i can't
stare down my demons right now
whatever's left there whatever is left
in the basement as
paulie said to rocky and rocky either
was that rocky six rocky balboa like
whatever is left there you got to go
down there and deal with that right and
or you could there's many versions of
that in many different stories right
like luke on dagobah when he's with uh
with yoda and you gotta go you know go
in there take only what you have with
you that sort of thing i remember
thinking like if i can't really confront
these things think these things through
figure out how i want to live my life
while i'm with him
uh
120 nights in 20 countries it's like
i'll never fully fix myself so so was
that ordained was that was that part of
the plan i kind of think so like by
going the right way the proof is in the
pudding of my life i'm doing what i'm
supposed to be doing obviously
in the relationship that i'm supposed to
be in uh we're about to have kids i work
with the right people i live in the
right state in the right city like i've
lined up those things and it's it's hard
to
when you're in it it's hard to see it
but then once you start getting
somewhere you can look back and be like
boy those pieces did really kind of
connect so i do believe that there is
some sort of plan and when you're doing
the right thing the plan
it kind of locks in in a way that that
you know it's working you know it's
working and i can tell you that when
i've been on those good runs like when
when my book's been out and i'm on tour
and really just every moment is is me
doing what i'm supposed to be doing um
time goes by faster uh you suddenly a
month passes and you're like wow that
was that was that was me at my best
there you go and then and then sometimes
you fall out of that but yeah i do think
there there is some sort of
i don't know divine intervention or plan
or
something that if you pay enough
attention to what you know is right
the rest will kind of just present
itself uh spike says bourbon you like or
dislike might affect future
subscriptions
uh
although phoenix just gave me two thumbs
up on bourbon
connor you're more of a beer guy fair to
say but you gave me the thumbs oh you
like the uh the monkey shoulder right
that's your
that scotch connor loves this thing it's
called monkey shoulder every time i'm
with him he's got to have the monkey
shoulder at all times eating chipotle
monkey shoulder morning coffee monkey
shoulder uh but it's scotch apparently
um i'm a tequila guy
i know as i've moved into more
conservative circles that conservatives
have to be drinking bourbon and whiskey
all the time they feel it makes them
manly uh i don't know if they think
tequila it's it's too mexican or
something but i love the agave i love
tequila my favorite bottle because
people always ask class azul the
reposado it's expensive but you only
need a tiny bit i like it on one rock
straight up and it is good i don't i
don't hate the brown liquor but i am it
is not a go-to for me but i hope you
will stick with me despite that
cinny says we'll all be praying that
everything goes well for baby one
and lady for later for baby number two
of course even though you're off the
grid could perhaps david or your
assistant just come on and say baby
delivered and all is well
regardless you'll be in our thoughts um
i think we could probably do something
like that i think we can make that
happen we'll we'll post something uh
just confirming that that baby one is
good to go and that you know we're good
and all that good stuff by the way
speaking of that um you know when i got
back from the tour people had given me
so much stuff especially from the locals
community community you guys were
awesome people that were giving us baby
gifts and custom clothes and people were
giving us
booze and books and hand-painted
drawings and candles and just so many
amazing things and i'm just so
appreciative like we sat yesterday
really finally going through everything
reading all the notes and everything and
uh much like blanche dubois i do depend
on the kindness of strangers even though
you're not strangers to me in a way
uh purdue says hi dave i get i get at
least a half dozen emails a day from
trump people raising money it's become
irritating and frankly feels stupid
poorly written stories about why i
should donate
i voted for him twice and long for him
to be in the white house but enough is
enough do you think they understand they
are alienating lots of people with the
constant begging well i wonder if your
email address has been sold to a whole
bunch of things that are maybe
ancillarily related to trump i'm not on
any you know i
basically unsubscribe from everything
because i'm so overloaded all day long i
can't open my phone anymore and just see
like the endless amount of stuff
fundraising or just generic stuff
otherwise
but i'm guessing that trump himself
whatever his
official mailing list is i'm guessing
that that one is probably not hitting
you up multiple times a day maybe once a
day and if they're asking for money once
a day that is quite annoying but i'm
guessing your email address probably got
sold
so you may want to figure out a backup
alias email you might want to try start
mail start mail.com so that's ruben uh
and just get you can get alias emails
that'll actually you know when you sign
up for things so it's not all going to
your main email address um but yeah the
fundraising thing it's like
man the politicians really need more
money is that like what this is really
all about it always seems like it's
about money um you know one thing that's
good in florida of course there's many
good things in florida but if ron
desantis makes the move for the
presidential run
he has a huge coffer right now i think
he's got like something like 130 million
bucks ready to roll and fortunately
because the democrats are so inept in
this state um he's not going to have to
spend a lot of money for his re-election
here
his uh governorship re-election so he'll
have a lot of money after so if he
decides to make the move hopefully he
won't need that much money but yeah the
money thing and just politicians always
asking for money and all that it's
annoying and it's boring and uh and it's
like i don't know like why would you
ever give someone money
who then in turn is going to raise your
taxes at least generally speaking
republicans raise your tax lower your
taxes but like the democrat people it's
like i'm going to give bernie money
here's bernie here's five more dollars
of my hard-earned money now raise my
taxes and give me socialism
two bits says when are when are you and
david gonna get a boat so you can host
parties on the water and perhaps give
interviews and do some reuben reports
from the boat that would be so cool uh
well at the moment we have been doing so
much house construction here which is
why occasionally during the show you're
hearing banging and glass breaking and
god knows what uh and just so much that
we're i'm a little stretched thin uh
financially at the moment to be getting
a boat uh i do know that right now
because of joe biden's economy
that here in florida at least it's
extremely difficult to get a boat
because they're just not getting things
everything's taken forever to the point
that getting used boats right now and i
think this is happening with cars as
well to get used boats uh is costing
more than to get a new one because
people just want them so quickly we're
hearing this also with we redid some
stuff in the kitchen to get appliances
people are willing to pay more for a
used appliance that means someone else's
old stove
just so that they can actually get it
instead of waiting six or eight months
so everything is screwy but i really
would love to get a boat one of the
things that i've really come to love
about florida there's lakes everywhere
uh and and i the boat culture is fun i
really do love fishing i usually do it
off a dock but uh yeah maybe we should
uh phoenix would you get on let's do the
reuben report yacht could you uh go to
yachts.net and see what we can come up
with let's go
uh arnie says what does freedom and
independence mean to you that's a good
one arnie for this
upcoming anniversary of the united
states of america
freedom and independence are your
ability to live as you see fit period
you cannot impose your beliefs on
someone and someone cannot impose their
beliefs on you this can be messy in a
country of 350 million people from all
walks of life who have different
religious and philosophical views uh you
know we have a multi-cultural a truly
multicultural society that has become an
incredible melting pot everyone brings
their foods their traditions their
languages their music their clothes into
america it all becomes part of that
thing as opposed to what's happened in
europe where people sort of cordon off
into their communities and they're part
of say the united kingdom
but they're very much identified as oh i
came from this country or that country
country we've done it so well here and
that also maybe is our weakness in a way
i think that's what woke-ism has shown
to be our weakness that that tolerance
that desire to fit in i mean if if we're
going to restore this thing
and you ask what is what is freedom and
independence
it's like we have to go back to that go
back to why did this country get founded
in the first place it was because people
wanted to make decisions for themselves
they did not want a king to rule them
and right now we do not want uh say an
inept president to rule us and if you
understand that if you understand that
boy it's it's tough i have certain
feelings about life and i wish i suppose
i wish i could control everybody but if
you understand well i don't really but i
understand certain people do
if you understand like no that's not how
it is all all a good country can do and
all that the united states should do is
create the conditions so you can live
how you want
and a couple rules around that
man that's what that's what it's all
about and we got to return to that and
that's why every politician that comes
in i'm going to solve all of your
problems and if only i had more tax
money we'd do this and if we took more
money from the rich we'd do that and if
we fought that war over there things
would be better and
it's like none of it's true
none of it's true there's one thing
that's true which is the more you stay
out of my life the more i can live the
life that i wish to live the more that
the people around me will do the same
and then we can build a good society
bottom up
hay says do you think that the u.s has a
chance to retake control of critical
food and medicine supplies from china
secondly why is bill gates the largest
owner of farmland in the u.s well first
on the gates thing i mean this is really
nuts we've talked about it a couple of
times on the show bill gates is now
the number one farmland owner in the
united states this is the same guy who
works with the world economic forum and
all of these giant
globalist
organizations whatever you want to call
them who are you know they want us to
eat bugs and no one will eat no one
alone anything and you'll be happier
than ever but for some reason bill gates
owns an awful lot of farmland do you
think that's weird bill gates is a bad
dude like something between whatever
he's doing with kovid and he's just he's
just not a good guy as far as getting
control of our food and i'll throw in
medicine there as well
whether it's taking some of that back
from china or not being so dependent on
russia for natural resources or whatever
it might be
we can't do it under this administration
these people want to break us and for
the few that maybe don't want to break
us they're just completely inept and
they're wrong about basically everything
um
so
we got to get rid of these people and
then i suppose we can but i would also
say at the same time you should have uh
a little power within your own life to
not be so dependent on all of these
systems that's actually there's a at
least about a half a chapter in dumper
in this country about just this i mean
if you have the means it's like grow a
little food if you can you know grow
some herbs if you have a little room get
a chicken coop i mean i know if you live
in a city it's tough to do these things
but being so dependent
that food made somewhere is going to
come to you and it's all going to work
all the time it's just not a great
strategy look what they did during cobit
and don't think they didn't learn a
little something from that
michelle says how do you brew your
coffee coffee maker french press pour
over etc well i'm in a bit of a coffee
conundrum right now so thanks for asking
michelle
in la we had this awesome
built-in machine it was a wolf machine
it was like built into the wall it was
so cool i could put fresh beans in the
morning press one button it would grind
them make the most beautiful cup of
coffee it was just so spectacular i
loved it then we got to florida we did
not have one of those machines i was
trying to get one of those machines but
thanks to joe biden it takes a long
freaking time to get anything as i just
illustrated so we've been waiting on one
of those machines and in the meantime i
started using the nespresso
i got to tell you i don't like the
nespresso am i going to get in some kind
of trouble for this certain coffee
people will be very upset about this um
i don't love the nespresso i don't think
it makes a great cup of coffee it's kind
of watery i've tried many many different
capsules
the best one that i found is they make a
carafe one that's a little more like a
slow pour over but i just don't think
it's great
so because i couldn't take that anymore
then i started doing the french press
again and that's when i first got into
coffee like 10 or 15 years ago the
french price if you do it right you just
slowly do it it only takes a few minutes
actually but you get those beans coarse
but not too fine and that whole thing
is really really nice but soon enough we
will have a built-in again
and we should be selling our own coffee
the reuben roast it was an idea we had a
while back we should let's circle back
on that uh bernardo says that now that
will whit
has left prageru and los a to end los
angeles for much greener pastures in
florida will dennis prager and the rest
of the prageru follow
i don't know i would love to get dennis
prager and his wife sue sue i know
you're watching you're a big fan of the
show
we want to get you guys here in florida
i send dennis almost every day i look
for houses
within a couple blocks of me and there's
just so much construction here
right now i send dennis and his wife
houses here because i would love for
them to relocate look i love everybody
at prageru shout out to marissa streit
and alan estrin and all of those guys
they're doing such great important work
when you see people like elon musk
waking up or joe rogan waking up or even
bill maher it's in large part because
places like prageru with these videos
that they've been doing for a decade now
woke up so many people that once you do
the brave thing when it's hard to do and
take the arrows for it
years later other people start repeating
your stuff when it's easier right i know
a little something about that myself
and it's all good it's all good but they
are in la right now it makes it harder
to hire at times because you know a
certain amount of people that are
somewhat like-minded say politically and
culturally they don't want to live in
l.a and i don't think la has much of a
future but i know they have very deep
roots there dennis has a great community
of friends and family there but i would
love to get them here there were tax
benefits and
alligator benefits and lizard benefits
did i tell you guys that yesterday
morning i was making my iced coffee open
up the freezer swear i could show you a
picture there was a uh a dead lizard in
the freezer
and i thought i love florida
a dead lizard in my freezer i'm not
kidding i'll show you later anyway uh i
hope they move here i really do uh cs
says when's david janet's cooking show
you've got to turn the reuben report
into a morning show with cooking and
lifestyle i mean come on man two gay
kings got to be able to do better with
women than the view that's funny um
so you know we're having kids we're
doing all this house construction he
hasn't been able to cook the way he
loves to cook uh also we don't have um
yet we don't have natural gas at the
house it's an electric stove and you
know chefs generally don't love electric
stoves you like to be able to really
work the gas
um
but part of the construction we're doing
here is putting in an outdoor kitchen so
we'll have at least propane there for
some uh for some burners um but he
doesn't want to be on camera uh he has
no ego in that way he loves cooking he
loves writing about cooking and the
cookbook is in the works i actually made
delay my third book so that we get the
cookbook out first because i really want
to get it out we have a we have a fun
sort of gimmick around it um but i don't
think there will be a cooking show but a
more a more loose morning show maybe
with some coffee and the egg and cheese
that sounds kind of good maybe we'll do
that connor you can have your monkey
shoulder be very exciting
uh nick says nerd question disney may
have ruined marvel but do you believe in
the multiverse if so do you think
there's an alternative reality where aoc
and eric swalwell are a conservative
power couple and nancy finally chose to
be a grandma man that would make the
multiverse worth it wouldn't it if those
people could be sane in some alternate
universe the multiverse is basically
without getting in too far into the
nerdy nitty-gritty of it the multiverse
is basically this idea well if you sort
of saw the last spider-man that there
are multiple
realities going on and you know we're
all we're just we happen to be living in
one ourselves right now but there are
many versions of this there's many
versions of you on different paths in
life and all of those things
i mean do i believe in it
there's sort of like an existentially
interesting idea around it and that
maybe in one of those multiverses you
are living your best life as you're
supposed to do and then and then that's
really like the challenge of life i
don't know there's some like jungian
idea there i don't know that i really
believe in it beyond the sort of fun
way to think about it in that regard um
by the way did not love the last
spider-man i know i know i'm just i
guess i'm just over all of this stuff
i'm overall that it's sad
it's sad it's part of growing up you
just realize that corporations buy all
your [ __ ] i used to have comic books as
a kid i still have a great comic book
collection i had an awesome spider-man
collection
and uh and the corporations just buy all
your stuff and then and then they ruin
it i watch this great interview with
george lucas i think i mentioned this a
couple weeks ago where he talks about
selling disney and he's like yeah i sold
it to white slavers but what are you
going to do
all right guys we got a cold clothes for
you in just a minute uh as always you
can join us for these q and a's if you
want to submit questions yourself at
reubenreport.locals.com part two of my
interview with south dakota governor
christie gnome who kept her state open
more than anyone more even than ron
desantis here in florida part two of
that is up across platforms the full
thing is already up on locals ad free
tomorrow we will have a celebration of
america on her upcoming birthday with
spencer clavin from the daily wire josh
hammer from newsweek and chris ruffo
from the manhattan institute and now we
leave you with mainstream media
freaking out
this is fascist in many ways this
decision and this policy will kill
people there is a war out there and we
need to recognize that we've got to
armor up i got the pitchforks you get
the gas and the torches the hell with
the supreme court we will defy them we
have to build the streets right now
elections are not enough